you've just been listening to a press
conference by governor greg abbott of
texas who talked about being livid at
the fact that he says he was misled by
the
officers and about the officer's
response to the uvalde shooting and
we heard him talk about his
investigation by
the texas rangers and the fbi as soon as
that information has gotten they will
give the information to the families
about the result of that investigation
he also talked about what strategies
what best practices have to be employed
what mistakes if any were made here he
was very strong in his opinion that they
should have eliminated the killer and
rescued the children uh and in response
to a question about 18 year olds being
allowed to get a long gun or a rifle the
texas the governor was very clear that
in texas for the last century and a half
18 year olds have been able to get long
guns and it's only in the last decade or
so that we've been hearing about school
shootings so i guess that
greg i'll start with you we've got a
livid governor uh justifiably livid as i
think everyone at this table is tonight
with the fact that we have been misled
as to what the facts were
well i think the important thing he said
was uh uh
and it's something that i said yesterday
is we only get to the scene of the story
after it happens and we should address
every variable every step that gets you
to that crime whether it is mental
illness schools family red flags the
fact that he said that this is a new
thing in a decade a half that kind of
points you in the direction of where the
answers are why are these things
happening more and more in this kind of
society is it something that has to do
with
not simply the availability of guns
because they have been available social
media uh it's a decline in education
it's a breakdown of the family but these
are a lot of things that we don't want
to talk about because
we've avoided these problems for so long
we've avoided these problems for 50
years i think you can say you know the
governor is livid and you could say well
maybe the police were incompetent or
they were they were afraid or they were
adherent to a doctrine that prevented
improvising but that is not my place
that's his place and that is the place
for the investigators to let them
investigate fully to tell the story
which is necessary you need the scrutiny
because there's going to be a next time
and the information you glean from this
time will help you in the next time
that's why it's important and it isn't
monday morning quarterbacking for
investigators or law enforcement or
family members survivors to question
these variables that is entirely their
right however i feel like as a media we
have to be very careful because we
monday morning quarterback five days a
week and we assume it's amazing to me
how we all become experts on every i
mean you know it's amazing and i didn't
go to school for any of this but somehow
i can have an opinion so i think be
humble
let them do the job let them talk about
what the police did or didn't do and try
to try to keep your again let the story
grow let the facts pile up you know uh
joey the the
the the governor was talking about and
and the state head of the uh uh
the department of public safety came out
and said that the school director i
think his name was mcgraw uh made a
mistake
and that they instead of dealing with
this guy ramos as an active shooter they
dealt with him as a barricaded shooter
now
you've got adherence to the chain of
command you're a military guy you've got
parents outside screaming yelling being
handcuffed
according to some being thrown to the
ground according to others or listening
to shots periodically through this
do you always listen to chain of command
in a situation where your gut is telling
you that there is an active shooter i'm
hearing an active shooter in there well
number one i'm a military guy not a
police guy there's two different things
well chain of command is chained to
command
fair fair
my reason for pointing that out is not
to assume any credibility i don't have
on the topic right right so
monday morning quarterbacking or voicing
the fact that expectations were not met
those are two very different things the
governor is the chief executive in that
state over there law enforcement it's
his job to say these are the protocols
we have active shooter is you run to the
gun
you go to the gun and you take it out
all right a hostage situation is very
much different i texted head seth
48 hours ago and said man this looks a
lot like they handled it like a hostage
situation that doesn't make sense they
did but i don't know why that is i don't
know what i was not in that room i was
not in the hallway i was not in that
school i can't tell you why that is we
all know that but what we know now is
that children are calling what we know
what we know now today
what we know now is that 11 35
officers go in they are being shot at
okay at 11 35 at 12 16 there's a 911
call shannon and one of the kids says
eight or nine of us are are alive and at
12 21 there are three shots that are
ringing out they've got an active
shooter why does it go from 12 21 to 12
50 to for them to figure out there's an
active ship so have a question i'd like
that answer too yeah okay well
and there were questions asked of these
officials were the 9-1-1 calls being
relayed to the commander on the scene
did they know that because if you're
treating this as a barricade situation
where maybe there are no children alive
in that room it's just the shooter
himself you're going to handle that
differently but when you have repeated
calls and i i feel like they're going to
release those 911 calls and it's going
to be really hard to listen to them
absolutely when children are begging
please send the police and they're in
there for 30 40 50 minutes we have no
idea what it was like for those kids in
there and it we are all furious and we
are all heartbroken and we always want
quick answers because as human beings we
want to try to make sense of this and we
cannot make sense of this but it does
take time to get there and greg as you
touched on we cannot pretend like our
society has not broken down at the
family level at the community level at
the church level that we have done
things that have actively ripped those
institutions apart and then wonder why
when there is a young man who is bullied
who is made fun of his family is
estranged and a complete mess that he
devolves further and further into these
online communities where people find
toxic relationships and ideologies that
they want a sense of self-esteem and
sense of being and all those places they
could have found it before are being
ripped away we cannot act like not
examining that and passing a bunch of
laws is going to make these young men
better and charles krauthammer had a
fantastic piece in 2012 that he wrote
after the sandy hook shooting i wish he
was still with us to make sense of this
if he could and it talks about a culture
of violence and how we have just broken
things down and we cannot pretend those
things don't matter
okay let's take a listen to the texas
department of public safety uh director
what he said earlier i'll get back to
you harold perfect
for the benefit of hindsight where i'm
sitting now
that of course it was not the right
decision it was a wrong decision period
there's no no excuse for that
but again i wasn't there but i'm just
telling you from what we know
that we believe there should have been
an entry at that as soon as you can
the chief of police of consolidated
infinite school district
he was convinced
and again i would go back and say you
know he was convinced at the time that
the there's no more threat to the
children and that the subject was
barricaded and that they had time to
organize with the proper equipment texas
embraces and teaches okay the active
shooter doctrine the active duty
doctrine as long as there's kids as long
as there's
someone's firing you go to the gun you
find them you neutralize them period
the active shooter doctrine harold
so first off i want to give governor
abbott a lot of credit he we're he we're
in a different party uh but i for him to
stand before the the press and answer
those questions uh real leadership uh is
accountable
and shares credit when things go right
and when they go wrong you're
accountable and i give them credit for
that two when he talks about the
responses i think he's talking about two
responses the response
of the officers on the ground which
obviously was a devastating disaster
uh a fatal disaster and then two what i
think he was equally limited at i heard
in his voice and heard in his words was
that he was lied to
by law enforcement afterwards so i
understand and we can all accept at a
painful way how mistakes can be made and
i listened to that mr mccraw there say
that this officer commander foolishly
wrongly thought that this was a
barricade situation
but once you leave there one thing the
chain of command is consistent with if
you lie to your superiors if you mislead
your superiors everyone that lied to the
governor
and the police chief and the mayor
should be fired immediately number one
number two this is a public safety
conversation that has to happen and
we've gotta we always try to say we want
to take politics out of things you can't
take politics out of things we are all
political beings and we have to just
accept that there's a a modicum of that
in the conversation so we got to talk
about schools and what has to happen you
touched on it yesterday judge there are
eight schools in that district we
learned and they're four security
resource officers that needs to change
the question around minors and mental
illness and whether or not you know
we've had mental illness in our society
forever we've had evil since the
introduction of mankind
australia has evil but they haven't had
a mass shooting since 1996. do we look
at what other countries are doing i
think we have to put all of that on the
table but i was most impressed with this
press conference because the governor
and the mayor uh this has all been in
two or three days here in two days they
have
talked they've let facts guide this
conversation and the response on the
scene a disaster a fatal disaster and
what i'm equally if not in a weird way
more disturbed by is that these that it
seems like law enforcement then lied to
the governor
and lied to the police uh deputy the
texas department of public safety leader
and lie to the mayor um and that is not
only fireable uh i i've got another
place in my mind with where those people
reserve for as well well all right joey
i'm gonna go back to you now um with
respect to uh the hardening of the
schools
we now know that the the teacher opened
the door at 11 27
at 11 28 she there's a crash and she
runs in to make a 911 call at 11 30 and
then she doesn't go back and close the
door and then what what is crazy about
it joey is that he then jumps a fence
with a long gun they say an hour 15 and
a bag of ammo and he shoots at the
school before he even gets into the
school they call the school resource
officer he drives by maybe he didn't see
the guy but then doesn't go back to the
school
no i think the last thing i heard and
that's my biggest problem with even
being on live tv talking about this is
whatever we say and talk about right now
something's probably going to change it
tomorrow and that's what's bothering me
so much about this is why can't they get
their ducks in a row and it's probably
because a lot of people are sitting
there looking at the severity of this
master
probably with their initial instinct
trying to cover their own tale exactly
and probably changing the narrative of
what happened in their own minds to the
point they believe it and that's part of
the problem with this resource officer
listen when i went to high school and he
may be a fantastic police officer now
but we called him barney five because
that was the presence he had
all right and why because you put him
somewhere that you don't think matters
because you're out there catching drug
dealers and murderers on the streets and
the school's a safe place well that's
changed that's not the posture we need
anymore i don't know anything about the
school resource officer there i believe
there were four officers first for a
district of eight schools i do know that
probably they usually put priority on
high schools rather than elementary
schools these are all things that have
to change but they're all things that
should have changed years ago right and
and you're talking about a rural area we
had a i believe it was a texas state
senator on fox and friends this morning
talking about frustration or it might
have been the mayor i believe it's
actually it was the mayor talking about
frustration if they need certain types
of resources say guidance counselors or
mental health counselors for students
they have to go to san antonio they have
to go to places 20 30 50 miles away
these are all things that have to be
addressed and just back to the security
of the school from my understanding it
was an awards day and that's why
security was lacked as far as entering
in earlier that morning right yeah and
if that's the case
common sense says you bring in more
officers you ask for more physical
persons yep and the crazy part about it
shannon is that apparently two months
before they had active shooter training
in that school district for the lower
school the elementary middle school and
high school yeah and there was a posting
on facebook at some point that the
uvalde swat team had gone around to
local businesses and schools and didn't
want people to be afraid say you're
going to see us in our full gear we're
coming so we can learn the layouts of
these places so if something like this
happens we're ready to go that's the
number one question i have is why the
uvalde swat team was not there by all
the accounts we've heard so far in these
press conferences they were not a factor
if they were in that community had the
ballistics protection equipment and
everything that they needed and they had
done drills and they had checked out
these schools specifically for this
that's my number one question i hope the
governor will get the answer to where
was that swat team why did it have to be
a border patrol team that showed up that
ultimately and they were even held off
for a while that had to force their way
in you know i may be wrong shannon but
my understanding is when one of the
school teachers called her husband who
was at a barber shop what wasn't he a
border guy
he grabbed he borrowed a rifle it wasn't
even his the barber shop went in himself
and shot he got his dog he's got his
wife
yeah got his kids out so
why did he get in and yet we've got 21
people as i i think we've got 19 cops in
the hallway from 1203 to 12.50 greg 19
cops kids are bleeding out while that is
happening well you know i admit you know
when when i hear about a terrible
tragedy like for me for the longest time
it was flight 93
and you always run through your head you
don't have to do this joey because
you're in the military you've been in
these situations but like you know i'm
in my head asking me like what would i
do what would i do at the bataclan or at
the pulse nightclub if i was there you
think that you will react one way but
you don't know uh i'd like to i'd like
to think i would do amazing things and i
would charge in there and and kill the
killer and and rescue people but you
don't know what happens to your brain
even if you're being trained for this so
i mean we're we're coming down pretty
hard on law enforcement and maybe they
deserve it but then again we're in the
we're not the experts here so i would or
just urge people like we don't even know
what what's the difference how do you
know the difference between an active
shooter situation and barricading
situation as we're criticizing that
the great the correct the girls
yeah the bullets are still going but and
the 911 calls are still coming in of
people that you know are alive these
like the monday people monday morning
quarterback this is what this guy's
trained to do right i mean no one shows
up at the gut fell show and say i i want
to i'm going to host this show i think i
can do it
there are three guys in this city who
try to do it as well as you want on the
west coast and they don't because you do
it well you you expect police officers
now we had a we had we talked about a
case where a guy got out of jail because
he uh escaped with apparently with uh
with a a a prison guard and he checked
out because they didn't make him sign
the note that morning about where they
were going right you have one failure
and you have a you have a cascading of
things we saw greg i agree with you but
i gotta tell you if it's my kids
i know we all can talk big the only guy
really here that's actually acted big is
joey here but if i saw something i saw
someone on a subway i got to think if i
saw a woman being raped like it was in
philadelphia i threw myself in front of
i do know this if my kids
are put in harm or put in danger um you
can put a bullet in my head that's right
a bullet a gun two guns three guns an
ar-15 i don't know what it is
i understand that i am not trained as an
expert good to be right there rip them
alive on this we're not ripping them
multiple types of law enforcement
agencies were involved in this all right
it is absolutely true you have to
identify an on-scene commander and let
them have that authority otherwise you
have people command center exactly
exactly so that that much of it i
understand
i don't know
what made them believe
that it was safer for the kids in the
room to stay outside the door but i 100
percent believe they acted on that
notion okay
that's the answer i want to know what
about when the cop
said if you need help yell help and one
of the kids said when that kid yelled
help that kid got shot
but i have a question about that because
i wanted any training and i wondered if
it was the killer himself pretending to
be the cop there's so much that we don't
know and unfortunately these babies who
survive this are the ones who are having
to provide that information we know how
many kids got out shannon i don't think
we do listen the school had more than
600 kids so they were breaking out
windows and taking kids out from other
parts of the school although those
officers and i'm with you greg i listen
my late father was a law enforcement
officer so the last thing i want to do
is cast any aspersions i'm just asking
questions that's it for now and my
father would have asked the same
question but look but governor abbott
the police union building in my
congressional district is named after my
father i'm a huge supporter of police
officers across the country
the the second part of this judge to
your point is what i understand you can
have the wrong reaction with the right
intentions at any given situation but
once the situation is over and you lie
about it
right that
that to me is what makes some of this
unforgivable a mistake does not negate
integrity that's the problem exactly all
right texas official stephen mccraw
getting emotional during the press
conference earlier take a listen
yeah thanks a lot
you know forget how i'm doing what about
the parents
those children
they forget about me because sometimes
or officers and stuff like that we take
an oath to uphold the law and protect
people you know
i used to
prosecute child abuse homicides
i never saw cops get emotional or more
emotional than they would with these
child abuse homicides
one of the things that this
governor talked about he was asked about
the difference between background checks
and mental health
and one of the things about mental
health and greg and i we we agree on
this it's just this amorphous blob we
don't know what it means you can lie
on an application
you can say
you know i don't have any mental health
issues i'm not on any on any
psychotropic drugs and under hipaa
the courts and i used to sign pistol
permits don't have the right to do a
check on your mental health issues will
we ever stop people who are mentally ill
from getting guns well that's something
charles krauthammer talks about in this
2012 piece too when he was practicing
psychiatry said it was much easier than
if you felt somebody really was a danger
to themselves or to other people
to get them into a facility and to do it
very quickly without a full-fledged
adjudication and and some of these
facilities across the country have been
closed they're just not available he
said it was much different in the 70s
than it was at the time he was writing
this in 2012. the mayor also this
morning talked about the fact that they
desperately wanted mental health
facilities there in uvalde they don't
have them like joey was saying that they
have to go um
cities away he said they had donated
seven and a half acres facility to
facility to be constructed there they
were excited the community was
supporting it and then they were told
they had to raise 26 million dollars and
he says our poor little community didn't
have it so they had to abandon the plans
for the mental health facility yeah
tough stuff uh we're now hearing that
joey there was a digital footprint more
than we thought that he was buying guns
he was in chat rooms uh he had indicated
in 10 more days something was going to
happen that along with some of the other
crumbs that we heard about he was
self-injuring himself he had violent
rhetoric at the at the job that he had
um that he was bullied because he had a
lisp and he wore eyeliner i mean there
are all these little crumbs but nothing
that really amounts to a point where
police can actually intervene one of the
biggest problems this is a atf form 4473
multiple pages this is what you have to
fill out this is the background checks
that that certain people want to be
universal all right you can fill that
out
and it gets sent off to a government
agency it's only as good as the vetting
of the government agency which is only
as good as the reporting of the local
agency whether that be school resource
school police officers whether it be
county uh sheriffs or city police that
form and that process is only as good as
the judge that decides we're going to
dismiss this because you're a minor or
the d.a that says we're not going to
prosecute this because this is going to
ruin your life we think you deserve a
second chance all of those things have
to be on board before any other
regulation on how we check people's
background
is effective so we can broaden the gun
transactions we add background checks to
but we still need to fix the background
check which goes all the way to the what
we've talked about for months which is
should we prosecute criminals should we
worry about their record if they've done
a violent crime go study the navy yard
four violent incidents two of them
involving a gun none of them made it to
the point that they went on a record so
he went not only did one of these and
got a gun but got a top secret security
clearance amazing yeah five pages before
go to break quickly
this is why we may need a longer wait
period and we might need to put more
people in charge of this to go to
investigate these things and put give
judges like you the authority that you
did not have years ago if you tell them
i can't wait to make this more happen
everyone looked at it like you we might
not have this hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else